you know what the challenges are of
trying to break a generational curse
within your family like imagine your
family everybody's been an alcoholic
you're like i want to stop drinking
alcohol everybody in your family has
been a drug addict or everybody you know
abusive relationships or you know
arrested or duis or poor or broke or
negative and it's like every you talk to
your mom then you talk to her family
then you talk to your gran like man i
see trends of everyone's language is the
same i don't want this life i don't want
to do that well if you ever try to break
your generational curses you're going to
have three enemies you're going to face
and i'm going to tell you about those
three today and by the way if this
message makes sense to you give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so let's get right into it you want to
change you don't want to be like some of
the things your mom and your dad your
grandma your grandpa that you're like i
don't want to be like this you guys been
poor all your life and all you talk
about is money's not
everything and money's the rule of all
evil i'm sorry all you guys ever argue
about is over money you talk about all
this stuff about me you know drinking
everything you guys do is drinking
drinking drinking and you guys
disrespect each other fight breaks and
i'm so done with this alcohol stuff i'm
so done with this drug stuff i'm so done
with this you know gambling stuff i'm so
done with this negative thinking stuff
i'm i'm so sick of it so you decide to
change three enemies you'll face one
is the people who have continued those
generational curses which could be your
parents
it could be your family
it could be a sibling
they indirectly
are hoping you change but at the same
time they've had that their entire lives
and they've lost the battle to
generational curses and indirectly
they sit there and they say if he
changes means i could have also changed
but i didn't so there's a part of
pushback because all they know is
gambling is how we do things in our
family all they know is alcohol drugs
being broke a language that's all they
know so they don't even know that
they're fighting you but that's going to
be one of your enemies not enemy in a
way where go home and fight your mom or
go home and fight your dad it's just
knowing it's an energy that's an enemy
because they've been like that for 58
years and they haven't chosen to change
yet you're choosing to change you're
gonna have some pushback they're the
second one
if you
have a certain generational curse that
you faced that means your surrounding is
probably around that as well could be
gangsters could be a lot of different
things so
that also that generational course from
the family brings an environment that
also believes into that same way of
living and same way of thinking which
means those people could now be the kids
of parents who are best friends with
your parents if that even makes sense
and you're not hanging out with them and
they're speaking the same language so
now your friends your peers your cousins
all the people you're hanging out with
they speak that language that's another
enemy how do you win that battle you're
going out to a club you're going out to
party going out to play sports you're
going out to
play video games playing whatever you're
doing they're speaking a language and
it's driving you insane they don't even
know they're doing it they're not doing
it intentionally but they've been like
that for 22 years because they've been
in that environment for 22 years and
maybe they don't yet have the courage
that you have to cut off that
generational curse and the last one is
going to be yourself the third enemy you
will face in trying to break a
generational curse is yourself because
the old self of you is still holding you
to not leave so no no no no hey i think
i can go out and do this no no no come
back no no no we're not going there dude
i don't want to be this person anymore
come on back here it's warm it's fuzzy
you don't want to go over there i want
to go over there that's you know the
whole venom thing you'd have the venom
gets in he's trying to get him out you
can't stick you're trying to leave
you're trying to leave that life and go
be a new person so three enemies the
people that pass down those curses to
you which is your family the people in
your environment and society that you've
been growing up like friends cousins all
that stuff because they're part of that
community and your old self that's going
to hold you back it'll be one of the
toughest battles you will ever face in
your life ever you will ever face in
your life but it'll be one of your
greatest victories you'll ever have you
can get all the trophies in the la in
life you can have all these trophies on
the you know office or you know wherever
you put them to say i when i won the
championship for this when i went
regional for this when i became mvp the
company for this when i did all that
stuff is great but there is a
non-existent trophy that nobody knows
about that only you know about nothing
will be more rewarding than you having
the guts and the courage to change and
be a complete different human being
if
you took something away from this
message that got you thinking give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
but i got another message i got another
video i want you to watch as well
the video is about how to recreate
yourself if you this is a very very old
video i just like maybe six years ago if
you've never seen the video on how to
recreate yourself click on this video to
find out how to recreate yourself take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]